ich denke jeder von euch hat sich schon
mal in seinem leben gefragt hey was wird
eigentlich öfter gegoogelt korruption
oder cannabis und davon dreht das
heutige video
darum dreht sich würde ich sagen wir
spielen heute nämlich das hanauer geben
und zwar sehen die schon oben
eingeblendet korruption wird monatlich
276.000 mal gegoogelt kann aber ist
würde ich sagen wenn heutzutage google
dementsprechend linke jahr feier und das
war richtig und jetzt müssen wir sagen
ob spector also der james-bond-film
öfter oder weniger oft gegoogelt wird
und hier findet ihr oben wieder werbe
video eingeblendet weil das ganze eine
kooperation mit google play ist also die
haben einfach gesagt de luca hast du dir
einfach irgendein spiel herunterzuladen
auf dem google places und das zu spielen
und ich natürlich ja und wenn ihr da
bock drauf habe dass ich so was öfter
machen findet ihr auch eine umfrage
eingeblendet wo wir sagen können ob ihr
das wollt oder nicht wird spector öfter
gegoogelt als cannabis meine damen und
herren ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung
ich denke weniger weil der film schon da
alles klar
direkt packt remake des to heart for you
the bridge choristes report tue und ich
habe eins
wir machen einfach mal star der new game
und wir sehen die presche oder alex
ferguson ich würde sagen alex ferguson
mit weniger häufig gegoogelt
das heißt ist auch richtig ecstasy
definitiv mehr nämlich 673.000 mal liege
hs würde ich sagen weniger als ecstasy
der begriff war mir jetzt auch nicht
geläufig
ja
ich philosoph paris wird locker
siebenstellig mal gegoogelt also 2,74
millionen mal
das ist irgendeine hunderasse die wird
weniger häufig gegoogelt bahrain
definitiv auch häufiger als die
hunderasse anna kurnikowa
das ist schwierig
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher ich
würde sagen weniger häufig nämlich aber
es ganz eng 368.000 notts county auch
auf jeden fall weniger erkenne ich nicht
also auch immer das sein soll chris
angel denke ich häufiger nämlich 201
tausendmal des streams
b
ich würde sagen häufiger nämlich weniger
häufig
aber ich bin schon in den top 10
american beauty oder carolina panthers
und ich würde sagen carolina panthers
wird häufiger nämlich 1,2 millionen mal
bupa keine ahnung was das ist definitiv
weniger häufig dann als nächstes qantas
auch weniger oft wo
ich esse airline
oder ich schieße
airline
genau
definitiv häufiger als das erdbeben von
haiti damals mut auf jeden fall weniger
ich würde sagen wir machen das ganze
interessant und ich habe jetzt noch drei
leben also ihr findet hier oben herzen
eingeblendet und das sind meine drei
leben jetzt botox wird definitiv
häufiger gegeben
mein erstes leben ist weg katy perry
oder cheneys take away wie ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung ich würde sagen
ja in die saeco weniger ist das wäre
doch noch viel viel mehr gewesen einem
server auf jeden fall häufiger als
chinesisches essen
dexter würde ich sagen sogar gleich viel
ich habe keine ahnung ich würde sagen
mehr nämlich eine million mal sogar
tatsächlich mosambik weniger als eine
million mal nämlich 246.000 mal the
bourne ultimatum weniger
ich dachte das wird noch eng surfing auf
jeden fall mehr also es hat nur drei mal
so viel prestige auf jeden gleich viel
gleichviel soll ich noch mal gleich viel
sagen
violine auf jeden fall mehr als die
prestige homer simpson geht auch ein
die ohne nicht mein letztes leben meine
damen und herren und wir starten mit
einem suchbegriff den ich so noch gar
nicht wirklich auf dem schirm hatte ich
habe mir das hanauer geben früher schon
so fünf sechs mal auf einem kanal
gebracht und dachte immer dass so sachen
die wirklich achtstellige monatliche
suchanfragen haben die krassesten sind
dies gibt da gab es so was wie apple
stars neymar oder irgendwie sowas aber
jetzt meine damen und herren wir haben
einen neuen preisträger neuen
spitzenreiter und zwar ebay 151
millionen mal ich denke alles wird
weniger häufig google als ebay also
caitlin jenner mit 1,5 millionen auch
krass aber definitiv viel weniger -
island auf jeden fall weniger als 1,5
millionen uno denke ich ist im hohen
sechsstelligen bereich sogar im
siebenstelligen bereich
wenn ich jetzt noch wüsste wer das ist
ich würde sagen weniger als 1,8
millionen nämlich auch nur 550.000 bei
prison break definitiv mehr
jetzt hat er wieder voll im heim des
supreme south park hatten wir gerade
schon habe ich das wieder vergessen ich
glaube allerdings dass das ganze
sechsstellig war also sogar nur
fünfstellig ok border collie auf jeden
fall mehr suchen relativ häufig suche
ich beispielsweise alle drei sekunden
hier ca virus weniger
ja
damit sind meine leben weg das war es
jetzt einfach wieder meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal ein leichter wenn ihr mehr vom
hanauer geben sehen wollte also mir
macht das einfach unglaublich viel spaß
zu sehen wie viel manche sachen einfach
gegoogelt werden wenn ihr das ganze
öfter sehen wollt dann schreibt man die
kommentare google litt ich nehme das
ganze gerade sogar mit der woche